Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory. History special on the statues of central London. And Dominic, we've really been kind of working our way towards where we are standing now, haven't we? Right from the very beginning, because we're now in Parliament Square and we're in front of the statue that triggered the whole statue debate which is the image of Winston Churchill. Yeah this great hulking image. Great hulking image which essentially has become a kind of lightning rod in the culture wars. So we've come on the one day when it's not covered with scaffolding or daubed with is a racist or Chelseaelsea fc yes or any of the other
感谢收听《历史其余部分》。如需收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory。伦敦市中心雕塑历史特别节目。多米尼克，我们其实一直在一步步走向我们现在站立的地方，对吧？从最开始就是这样，因为我们现在就在议会广场上，正对着引发了整场雕塑大辩论的那座雕塑，也就是温斯顿·丘吉尔的雕像。是的，这个庞大的雕像。这个庞大的雕像基本上已经成为了文化战争中的某种风暴中心。所以我们偏偏挑了这一天来，这天它没有被脚手架覆盖，也没有被涂上“是个种族主义者”或“切尔西足球俱乐部”之类的字样
things that it's actually you know in the last um so yes so on the edge of parliament square he's he's facing big ben he's this incredibly imposing sort of heroic figure um so supposedly tom churchill ringed 20 years before he died he ringed this area of parliament square for himself on a map and said that is where my statue will go and they the guy the sculptor did it and apparently had to redo it because it looked too much like mussolini um well he does look his head there to make churchill's head smaller because otherwise he would look like mussolini but anyway here he is the great old man of 20th century british politics and the sort, you know, for so long seen as the incarnation of the Dunkirk spirit, the British bulldog, all the cliches that we grew up with, I suppose, didn't we? And he is the reason, to some extent, he's the reason we're having this, we're doing these podcasts at all.
或者其他任何……其实你知道，在过去的……所以是的，在议会广场的边缘，他正对着大本钟，他是一个极其宏伟、堪称英雄式的人物……据说，汤姆，丘吉尔在去世前20年，在地图上圈出了议会广场的这片区域给自己，并说“我的雕像就要放在那里”。他们——那个雕塑家照做了，但据说不得不重做，因为看起来太像墨索里尼了……好吧，他看起来确实很像，他们把丘吉尔的头做小了一些，否则他看起来就会像墨索里尼。不管怎样，他就在这里，20世纪英国政治伟大的老人，长期以来一直被视为敦刻尔克精神、英国斗牛犬精神的化身，以及我们成长过程中所熟悉的一切陈词滥调，我想，不是吗？从某种程度上说，他正是我们做这些播客的原因。
Because his statue has become so controversial um what do you think about it well i i i think in a way it it's the the debate around the statue has become divorced from from any historical debate about church himself yeah i think essentially people come here and put mohicans on it or door bit or whatever simply because it's a fun way to annoy people who will be annoyed by people doing it's sort of edible isn't it i mean it's kind of i don't think it's even that i don't think they even people even care about churchill particularly i think it's just i think if you're if you're on if you're on a demo and you want to annoy the people that you're on a demo protesting against you know that defacing
因为他的雕像已经变得极具争议，呃，你对它有什么看法？嗯，我觉得在某种程度上，围绕这座雕像的辩论已经脱离了关于丘吉尔本人的任何历史辩论。是的，我觉得本质上人们来这里给它戴上莫西干发型，或者涂抹它，或者诸如此类，纯粹是因为这是一种惹恼那些会被这种行为激怒的人的好玩方式。这有点像恶作剧，不是吗？我的意思是，我觉得甚至都不是那样，我觉得人们甚至都不是特别关心丘吉尔。我觉得，如果你在参加游行，你想惹恼你抗议的对象，你知道涂污
churchill will get a rise out of them i think it's more it's a way it's a way of pissing off the gammon and on the topic of gammon i should just mention yeah the single funniest fact in our first episode um we did we uh we looked at the statue of of um general napier and i forgot to mention that he the statue of uh sir charles james napier uh was actually sculpted by somebody called george gammon adams so see if i was a more cynical man i would think that you've spent the first few moments of this podcast just waiting for an opportunity to bring out your napier gammon joke that you forgot to mention two podcasts ago um churchill that but it's interesting that he's he's just got the one name hasn't he i mean well he's got the one they want stupid thing to say
丘吉尔会激怒他们。我觉得这更像是一种激怒“加蒙”（英国保守白人男性）的方式。说到“加蒙”，我顺便提一下，是的，我们第一集里最有趣的事实——我们看了……呃……纳皮尔将军的雕像，而我忘了提查尔斯·詹姆斯·纳皮尔爵士的雕像实际上是由一个叫乔治·加蒙·亚当斯的人雕刻的。所以，如果我是个更刻薄的人，我会觉得你刚才在这集播客刚开始的时候，一直在等一个机会，好抖出你两个星期前忘讲的那个“纳皮尔-加蒙”笑话……丘吉尔那个……但有趣的是，他只有一个名字，不是吗？我的意思是，呃，他只有一个名字——多么愚蠢的一句话。
he's just got the one word on his plinth so there's no winston there's interesting that he's just got the one name, hasn't he? I mean, well, he's got the one name, what stupid thing to say. He's just got the one word on his plinth. So there's no Winston, there's no dates, there's just Churchill. No explaining who he was. No, but I suppose the assumption was you wouldn't need it. I mean, Churchill was just a titanic figure. And actually, I will say this. He's one of the, you do see people looking at it as they walk past. There are people right now looking at it,
他的底座上只有一个词，所以没有温斯顿，有趣的是，他只有一个名字，不是吗？我的意思是，呃，他只有一个名字——多么愚蠢的一句话。他的底座上只有一个词。所以没有温斯顿，没有日期，只有丘吉尔。没有解释他是谁。没有，但我想大家的假设是你们不需要解释。我的意思是，丘吉尔简直是一个泰坦般的人物。而且事实上，我要这么说。他是那种……你确实会看到有人路过时看着它。现在就有人在看着它，
and they're actually about to take a photo, which is not true of most of the statues we covered in the previous podcast so it's still a statue that clearly well it matters i know that's a weird thing to say the statue of a man who died in 1965 but it does matter to people for good or real so i think on the issue of statues a huge issue is why why is the been put up? And as we have kind of clearly realised over the course of the previous two podcasts, every figure has a kind of ambivalent record. You can always find a dark side. You can always find complications. We haven't had any saints yet, have we? We haven't had any saints. And so it matters why he's put up was was it is this statue commemorating uh churchill's
他们甚至正准备拍照，我们之前播客中讨论的大多数雕像可没有这种待遇。所以这依然是一座显然……嗯，很重要的雕像——我知道对于一个1965年去世的人的雕像来说，说它重要听起来很奇怪，但它对人们来说确实很重要，无论是好是坏。所以我觉得，关于雕塑的问题，一个巨大且核心的问题是：为什么要树立这座雕像？正如我们在前两集的过程所清楚意识到的那样，每个人物都有着某种矛盾的评价。你总能找到黑暗的一面。你总能找到复杂性。我们到现在还没遇到过什么圣人，对吧？我们没有任何圣人。因此，为什么要为他树立雕像就很重要了——这座雕像是在纪念丘吉尔的
racism is it commemorating his attitudes to india is it commemorating his record in in the general strike i don't think it's it's in this poll position for any of those reasons this statue is here because he is the man who ensured that britain stayed independent in 1940 against the worst tyranny that the world has ever faced on is great keep it coming and and for that reason if there has to be statues i'm happy for there to be a statue here of churchill if anybody i just want to say this if anyone's listening to this from the daily mail tom holland is not available to write yeah but there's a but dominic dominic there's but, which is that in general, I find the, this kind of class. Oh, I'm about to be arrested.
种族主义吗？是在纪念他对印度的态度吗？是在纪念他在大罢工中的记录吗？我不认为它占据这个C位是因为这些原因。这座雕像之所以站在这里，是因为他是那个在1940年确保英国保持独立、对抗世界有史以来面临的最糟糕暴政的人。这很棒，继续保持。正因如此，如果必须有雕像的话，我很高兴这里能有一座丘吉尔的雕像。如果有人……我只想说，如果《每日邮报》的读者有人在听这个，汤姆·霍兰德现在没空写……是的，但是……但是多米尼克，多米尼克，但是……那就是，总的来说，我发现这种……这种政客群星闪耀的阵列……噢，我快要被捕了。
What a shame that you're being silent. I'm about to be arrested. I don't like this kind of galaxy of political luminaries. Oh, I love this. I love a pantheon. No, I don't. Because, because to be honest, I'm happy for Churchill to be here. See, I would come here with my son and walk around and say, he's him. This is so-and-so. I think this is a great educative square, this space. So this is Parliament Square.
你保持沉默真是太遗憾了。我快要被捕了。我不喜欢这种政治显贵的星系。噢，我喜欢这个。我喜欢万神殿。不，我不喜欢。因为，说实话，我很高兴丘吉尔能在这里。你看，我会带着我的儿子来这里，四处走走，然后说：“这就是他。这就是某某某。”我认为这是一个伟大的具有教育意义的广场，这个空间。所以这就是议会广场。
So in a sense, this is the kind of figurative representation of our democracy. Yeah. So it matters hugely who is here. Well, that's why you have Churchill, because he defended British democracy in 1940 when it was in battle. I'm happy for Churchill to be here if we have to have statues. But I do think that there is a case for saying in Parliament Square that we, rather as with the cenotaph, which symbolises the war dead, without reference to generals, without reference to even to kind of representative figures of the soldiers who fought in the war. And I think therefore is all the more moving for it.
从某种意义上说，这就是我们民主制度的具象化代表。是的。所以谁能留在这里至关重要。嗯，这就是为什么这里有丘吉尔，因为他在1940年民主制度陷入苦战时捍卫了英国民主。如果非得有雕像的话，我很高兴丘吉尔能留在这里。但我确实认为，在议会广场上，我们完全有理由说——就像象征阵亡将士的阵亡将士纪念碑那样，不提及将军，甚至不提及在战争中作战的士兵的代表性人物，而且我认为正因如此，它才更加令人动容。
I think that there would be a way of summoning up the traditions of British democracy here that didn't rely on hugely... A massive stone ballot box. Is that what you want? Well, I'm not a sculptor. So I, you know... I think nations need heroes.
我认为，这里完全有一种方式来唤醒英国民主的传统，而不需要依赖于巨大的……一个巨大的石头投票箱？你是想要这个吗？嗯，我不是雕塑家。所以，你知道……我认为国家需要英雄。
And I think elected Democratic representatives are as good as any. But politicians, by their definition, kind of aren't heroes and are, by definition, divisive figure. So if Churchill, who saved the country, who did as much as anyone to defeat fascism is a is a controversial figure then so is everyone else so we're now standing in front of a man who who i know you you have you have said let's one point about churchill churchill was divisive when he died in 1965 his former sworn political adversaries so people like clement atlee said he was a great man atlee said you know the great extinguishment of our time nobody opposed his statue nobody opposed his state funeral so i think but they do now don't they they do now and that's the point that's the point is that he's now become a divisive figure
我认为通过选举产生的民主代表和任何人一样好。但政客就其定义而言，算不上什么英雄，而且根据定义，他们是具有分裂性的政治人物。所以，如果拯救了国家、为击败法西斯做出巨大贡献的丘吉尔是一个充满争议的人物，那么其他人也一样。所以我们现在正站在一个人的雕像前……我知道你曾经说过……关于丘吉尔，让我们说一点：丘吉尔在1965年去世时是充满争议的，他昔日的死敌、政治对手——比如克莱门特·艾德礼——都说他是个伟人。艾德礼说，这是我们时代最伟大的熄灯号。没有人反对他的雕像，没有人反对他的国葬。所以我觉得……但他们现在反对了，不是吗？他们现在反对了，这就是重点所在——重点在于，他现在成了一个具有争议的人物。
okay right i'm i'm i don't want to get cross so i don't start crying which would be uh which would be worse so but we're now in front of david lloyd george who i know you you absolutely you essentially wanted to cancel yeah it's a terrible statue it's a it looks like a melting ice lolly it's from 2007 he's got his cloak like he's doing an enormous great yeah breaking wind it's a tremendous effect he's got this sort of billowing cloak behind him he's wearing a bow tie isn't he um so ll Lloyd George, I suppose, the argument for him is, you know, reforming Liberal Chancellor, one of the founding fathers of the welfare state,
好吧，好吧，我……我不想生气，免得我开始哭泣，那可就……那可就更糟了。但我们现在正站在大卫·劳埃德·乔治的雕像前，我知道你……你基本上想“取消”他。是的，这是一座糟糕的雕像。它看起来像一根融化的冰棍。它建于2007年，他的斗篷看起来就像他在放一个无比巨大的……是的，在放屁。这是一个非常震撼的效果。他身后拖着那种波浪起伏的斗篷，他还戴着领结，不是吗？呃……劳埃德·乔治，我想，支持他的理由是：他是改革派的自由党财政大臣，福利国家的奠基人之ー，
ultimately the man who won the war, so-called, in World War I. The argument against him is unbelievably corrupt, even by 21st century standards. You know, flogged peerages for money, stabbed all his colleagues in their back and didn't get off with his daughter-in-law a hideous womanizer cuckolded his own son which i think is pretty bad form at any moment in history i don't there's ever been a time when that's been regarded as and yeah sort of i just couldn't be trusted around women. I mean, in a Me Too age,
归根结底，他是第一次世界大战中所谓赢得战争的人。反对他的理由则是：即使以21世纪的标准来看，他也腐败得不可思议。你知道的，卖官鬻爵，背后捅所有同事的刀子，还和儿媳妇勾搭不清——这是一个极其好色的人，居然给自己戴绿帽子，我认为在历史上任何时期这都是相当恶劣的行为。我不认为曾经有过哪个时代，这种行为会被认为……而且，是的，他在女性面前简直不可信。我的意思是，在“我也是”（Me Too）时代，
to me, Lloyd George is a bit vulnerable, actually. Now, this will raise hackles among our Welsh listeners because he's the only Welshman, I think, we've had in these three podcasts, and they would want him. And, of course, liberals. He's a great liberal hero. Well, the thing is, I think the argument is either
对我来说，劳埃德·乔治其实有点站不住脚。现在，这会惹恼我们的威尔士听众，因为他是我们在做这三期播客中遇到的唯一的威尔士人，他们会希望维护他。而且，当然还有自由主义者。他是伟大的自由党英雄。嗯，问题是，我觉得争论的焦点要么是
you have everybody, which is effectively what we've got, so in which case don't cancel any of them i wouldn't really cancel them or get rid of the lot now well all that said tom i said i wouldn't really cancel him and now we're on to a very very very interesting candidate so this is somebody we're now in front of jan christian smuts 1870 to 1950. So this is a fascinating one. The most visitors to this square will not recognize the name, and they won't know why he's here. He's a Boer War general who fought against the British, then is kind of reconciled to Britain.
要么你把所有人的雕像都留下——这实际上就是我们目前的状况，既然如此，那就别取消任何人，我其实并不想取消他们，或者把他们全都赶走。好吧，话说回来，汤姆，我刚才说过我并不是真的想取消他，现在我们迎来了非常非常非常有趣的一位候选人。这就是我们现在面对的扬·克里斯蒂安·史末资，1870年至1950年。所以这是一个引人入胜的人物。大多数来这个广场参观的游客都不会认出这个名字，也不会知道他为什么会在这里。他是一名布尔战争将军，曾与英国作战，后来与英国达成某种和解。
He fights in World War I, and he is the South African prime minister during World War II. And I'm sure people who listen to our sister podcast, We Have Ways, about the Second World War, will know that there were contingency plans that if Churchill died in World War II, Smuts would become prime minister of the United Kingdom. So in his day, a colossal figure, now kind of forgotten in Britain at least. But of course, because he was a white south african there is baggage i mean he wasn't you know fully pro-apartheid he wasn't part of the
他在第一次世界大战中参战，并且是第二次世界大战期间的南非总理。我相信听过我们关于二战的姊妹播客《我们有办法》的听众会知道，当时曾有应急计划：如果丘吉尔在二战中牺牲，史末资将成为英国首相。所以，在当年，这是一个庞然大物般的人物；但现在，至少在英国，他已经被遗忘了。但当然，由于他是一个白人南非人，这就带来了历史包袱——我的意思是，他并非完全支持种族隔离，他不是种族隔离政权的一部分，但他支持种族隔离政策（segregation），他对种族的看法对我们来说是无法接受的。所以实际上，如果你要玩“保留还是取消”的游戏，他非常脆弱。你不这么觉得吗？嗯，他是这里的众多非英国籍雕像之一。是的。我觉得这有点问题，因为我实际上认为这是某种帝国宿醉。当然，就他而言是的。但我认为我们接下来还会看到甘地和曼德拉的雕像。
apartheid regime but he was pro-segregation and he had views about race that would be unpalatable to us now so actually if you're going to do the keep and cancel game, he is very vulnerable. Do you not think? Well, so he is one of a number of statues here that aren't British. Yes. I think there's an issue with that because I actually think it's a kind of imperial hangover. Of course it is in his case, yeah. But I think we're going to come to the statue of Gandhi and of Mandela as well.
我觉得从某种意义上说，你可能会说我们是在向他们所代表的传统致敬，但在某种程度上，我们也是在某种程度上将他们据为己有。这就像我们把他们当作依然是大英帝国的子民来对待。但他曾是全球大英帝国的一部分。是的，我知道。但本质上，这是一个非常非常帝国的空间。
I think in a sense, you may say we're paying respect to the traditions that they represent, but in a way we're also kind of appropriating them. And it's like we're treating them as though they're still subjects of the British Empire. But he was part of a global British empire. Yes, I know. But so essentially, this is a very very imperial space yeah precisely not just because
是的，确切地说，不仅是因为这里有史末资，还因为这里同样有曼德拉和甘地。完全同意。所以我觉得我们确实在将印度和南非的伟大人物据为己有……好吧，他们曾是……我的意思是，史末资是英国故事的一部分。所以史末资，我同意。因此，曼德拉和甘地则略有不同。但史末资……我的意思是，这也是一座非常奇怪的雕像，因为他看起来像是在
we've got smuts here but because we've got mandela and gandhi as well agreed and i think so i think we are we are appropriating you know the great figures of india and and of south africa well they were part i mean smuts was part of Britain's story. So Smuts, I agree. So Mandela and Gann are slightly different. But the Smuts, I mean, also, it's a very odd statue because he looks like
滑冰。他确实是。他双手背在身后。是的，他确实是。就像他在冰面上滑行一样。大步流星向前。
he's ice skating. He does. He's got his hands behind his back. Yeah, he does. Like he's kind of gliding across the ice. Striding forth.
现在，轮到我最喜欢的历史人物之一了，我们在以前的播客中讨论过他。首相世界杯，对吧？首相世界杯。他是帕麦斯顿子爵。是的。据说——虽然可能是戏说——他在80岁时在台球桌上和一个女佣行房时去世了。是的，呃……你兄弟会称之为“外交”，我兄弟会称之为“绝对的大猛男”，我认为这样说很公平：炮舰外交，痛击外国人……他实际上是个废奴主义者，所以如果以废奴为标尺，他通过了考验，可以加分。但随后他也有减分项，因为他……
Now, one of my favourite historical characters, we've talked about him in the podcast before. The World Cup of Prime Ministers, didn't we? The World Cup of Prime Ministers. He's Viscount Palmerston. Yes. Supposed yes supposedly though apocryphally i think died while deflowering a
想要支持南方邦联，因为他恨美国。所以他认为这是我们粉碎美国的方式，我们本该支持南方邦联……他是维多利亚时期帝国主义者的模范。帝国主义者，是的，他确实是。他毫不掩饰。如果他现在在这里，我的意思是，他绝对会站在……
maid on a billiard table at the age of 80 yes um uh what your brother would call diplomacy what my brother would call a massive lad i think it's fair to say gunboat diplomacy smiting foreigners um he he was an he was an abolitionist actually so slavery is the yardstick he's got he passes he's got bonus points but then he's got debits because he um wanted to support the confederacy because he hated america so he thought this is our way to smash america so we should have supported the confederacy um he's he's the model of a victorian imperialist imperialist yeah he is he is. He's unashamed. If he were here now, I mean, he would absolutely be on...
但同样，如果我们套用我们一直在相当不一致地应用的那个标准，你也可以说，雕像就是一座历史画廊。这就像是一个杜莎夫人蜡像馆。嗯，议会广场不就是这样的吗？我的意思是，我们周围环绕着一座历史画廊。这就像是一个杜莎夫人蜡像馆。嗯，议会广场不就是这样的吗？我的意思是，我们被一排……所以我的观点在这里摇摆不定，就像一辆购物手推车。我喜欢帕麦斯顿。
But again, to apply the standard that we have actually rather inconsistently been applying, you could say that statues are a gallery of history. It's a kind of Madame Tussauds. Well, that's what Parliament Square is. I mean, we're surrounded by a gallery of history. It's a kind of Madame Tussauds. Well, that's what Parliament Square is. I mean, we're surrounded by a line of... So my argument is veering all over the place here, like a shopping trolley. I like Palmerston.
我喜欢他在那里。我认为这是维多利亚时期的一段历史。这是一座意气风发的雕像。这是一座非常棒的雕像，不是吗？他看起来像一个典型的维多利亚时期的政治家。确实如此。下一位也是如此，那就是德比伯爵。
I like the fact he's there. I think it's a bit of Victorian history. It's a dashing statue. It's a very good statue, isn't it? He looks like a classic Victorian statesman. He does. As does the next person, who is the Earl of earl of derby
哦，每个人都喜欢德比。我的意思是，事实上，你想取消德比伯爵吗？我得从这些人群中挤过去，这里有许多朝圣者的队伍，许多外国游客专门来看……这里底部有一个非常可爱的浮雕：1833年的下议院，老德比正在发言台前大显身手。所以他做了22年的托利党领袖，他曾三次出任首相——不过我想每次大概也就维持了一个星期左右吧？我是夸张了……这里他是牛津大学校长，真是个大人物。另一边是：中央执行棉荒救济委员会。
oh everyone loves derby i mean actually he wants to cancel the earl of derby i'm gonna fight through these crowds here crowds of pilgrims are genuflecting a lot of foreign tourists come specifically to look at the and there's a lovely um relief at the bottom the house of commons 1833 there's the old darby doing his stuff at the dispatch box so he was a tory leader for 22 years he was prime minister three times but i think sort of for a period of about a week on each occasion um i'm exaggerating uh here he is as the chancellor of the university of oxford what a man on the other side he's the central executive cotton famine relief committee committee oh it's kind uh and uh cabinet council 1867 so again a massive lad so um disraeli put this up 1874 you know what disraeli said no we have raised this statue to him not only as a memorial
噢，真是……还有内阁委员会1867年会议。所以，又是一个绝对的大猛男。所以，迪斯雷利在1874年竖起了这座雕像。你知道迪斯雷利说了什么吗？不。我们为他竖立这座雕像，不仅是为了纪念，
but as an example not merely to commemorate, but to inspire. So that's why there are crowds of foreign tourists. Yeah, they've come to be inspired. Genuflecting before him. Now, I think our producer, Tony, has been haranguing me throughout these three episodes about relevance. And I think the Earl of Derby is a hard one for me to justify because whatever his achievements whatever his political
更是为了作为榜样；不仅是为了缅怀，更是为了激励。所以这就是为什么这里会有成群的外国游客。是的，他们是来寻求启发的。在他面前顶礼膜拜。现在，我觉得我们的制作人托尼在这三集节目中一直就“相关性”一词对我唠叨不休。我认为德比伯爵对我来说是一个很难辩护的人物，因为无论他的成就有多大，无论他的政治
importance in the 19th century if relevance is your yardstick which I absolutely don't think it should be but if it is the Earl of Derby
重要性在19世纪有多高，如果“相关性”是你的衡量标准——虽然我绝对不认为它应该是——但如果是的话，德比伯爵
is relevant to nobody he does have magnificent whiskers to the city of Derby yeah I don't know that he had any great
和任何人都毫无关联。他确实有着壮丽的络腮胡子……对于德比市来说……是的，我不知道他对德比这个地方有什么深厚的感情。所以他并不是在为德比郡出战？他可不是那种至死不渝的公羊球迷（德比郡绰号公羊）。当他想到布莱恩·克拉夫（著名足球教练）时……抱歉，这个梗会让一些不看足球的听众一头雾水。但他有着非常棒的络腮胡子，所以是的，这绝对是大羊排胡须（mutton chop whiskers）的绝佳代表，这是理发师的最爱——当然不是给理发师理发啦，显然。
you know affection for Derby as a place. So he's not batting for Derbyshire? He's not a ram till I die. When he thinks of Brian Clough. Sorry, that's a reference to be lost on some of our non-football fancying listeners. But he's got great whiskers so yeah he does a great one for the mutton chop it's one for the barbers well not for the barbers obviously no
好吧，现在我们要迎来一位比较进步的人物了，汤姆。是的，我们所有的雕像都是男性，除了你的布狄卡——尽管那是上一次的节目了，对吧？我其实已经记不清了，这次散步实在进行了太久。非常近代的雕像。你想给我们介绍一下吗？这就是米利森特·福 Fawcett，伟大的女权运动领袖，这座雕像是什么时候竖起来的？2018年？2019年？经过了长时间的争取。
okay now now we've got to a more progressive one tom yeah so we all we've done all men except for your buddhica um although she was last time wasn't she i've actually lost track this walk has been going on for so long. Very recent statue. Do you want to tell us about it? So this is Millicent Fawcett, the great suffragette leader, which went up 2018, was it? 2019? After a lengthy campaign.
2018年，你没记错。我刚刚在看我的笔记。2018年。卡罗琳·克里亚多·佩雷斯。是的。我认为这很棒，完全赞成这一点，尽管你知道吗，连《卫报》都曾发表专栏文章说她不应该拥有雕像，他们说她不是一个激进的女权运动者……不过四周雕像周围有许多照片……你看，这就是
2018, you're right. I was just looking at my notes. 2018. Caroline Criado. Yeah. And I think it's great all in favor of that although you know what the guardian ran columns saying she shouldn't have a statue they said she wasn't a radical uh suffragette um they do have pictures all around the side well you see that that's you
你看，这就是我喜欢它的原因——因为……有一种观点认为，把个体等同于整个运动的局限性之一，在于它过于聚焦于个人。但在这里，他们放了许多人的照片，大部分是女性，但也不完全是女性，他们都为女权运动做出了贡献。所以其实她们全都是女性。不，我不觉得全是。上面有哪个是男的？
see that's why i like it is is because one of you know kind of saying that one of the problems with um the argument that individuals can sum up entire movements is that it does very much focus attention on the individual. But here they've got photographs of people, mostly women, but not exclusively, who contributed to the suffragette. So I think they're all women, actually. No, I don't think so. Who's a man there?
有个伙计。乔治·兰斯伯里。好吧，所以确实有个男的。工党领袖。对，我们有几个男的。还有潘克斯特一家的男丁——工党领袖。对，我们有几个男的。我们有潘克斯特家族的人。所以他们更加激进。我以为汤姆刚才只是在对纪念碑上的女性说些刻薄话，但并没有。
There's a chap. George Lansbury. Okay, so there is a man. Leader of the Labour Party. Yeah, we've got a couple of men. We've got the Pankhurst a man. Leader of the Labour Party. Yeah, we've got a couple of men. We've got the Pankhursts. So they're the more radical. I thought Tom was just being disobliging about the woman on the memorial, but no.
而且上面还有这样一句话。她实际上拿着……你知道，这面旗帜，我猜。勇气随时随地召唤勇气。非常美好。非常感人。我认为它实际上是一件精美的公共艺术品。确实如此。她裙子的布料……
And it has this message. She's actually carrying, you know, this flag, I guess. Courage calls to courage everywhere. Very nice. Very moving. I think it actually is a lovely bit of public art. It is. And the fabric of her dress.
你几乎……你几乎可以触摸到它。你随时可以触摸到它。你真的可以触摸到它。事实上，我就要去摸……但是汤姆，你知道吗？是的，她其实也是个可以被“取消”的人。她曾非常激烈地反对爱尔兰地方自治，她为了爱尔兰地方自治的问题甚至退出了自由党，加入了自由联合党。所以，你知道，来自都柏林的游客可不会把她当成旅游的第一站。我想这也再次强化了这样一点：每个人都不是圣人，如果你要玩这种“取消”游戏，你几乎可以为任何历史人物找到借口。既然说到没有人是圣人，我们的下一座雕像就是……本杰明·迪斯雷利。本杰明·迪斯雷利，维多利亚时代的鲍里斯·约翰逊。
You can almost... You can almost touch it. You can always touch it. You can touch it. In fact is and the fabric of her dress you can almost you can always touch it you can always touch it in fact i'm going to but tom do you know what yeah she again is everybody's cancelable she was opposed to very violently opposed to home rule for ireland he left the liberal party over the issue of home rule to join the liberal unionists so you know visitors from dublin she's not going to be first stop on their list and i suppose that reinforces the point that everybody that none of them are saints that if you are in this sort of cancellation game you can find a reason for any historical character and talking of no one being saints our next one is um benjamin disraeli benjamin disraeli boris johnson of the victorian
本杰明·迪斯雷利。维多利亚时代的鲍里斯·约翰逊。是的，我的意思是，“迪兹”是终极的帝国主义者，对吧？我的意思是，他就是那个让维多利亚女王成为印度女皇的人。他是个迷人的江湖骗子，对吧？他是个政客骗子。他是个江湖骗子。他是个迷人的骗子。他和帕麦斯顿有点“鲍里斯”式的风格。
world yeah i mean dizzy is the ultimate imperialist right i mean he's the man who made queen victoria Benjamin Disraeli. Benjamin Disraeli. The Boris Johnson of the Victorian world. Yeah, I mean, Dissey is the ultimate imperialist, right? I mean, he's the man who made Queen Victoria Empress of India. He's a charming shyster, isn't he? He's a mountebank. He's a mountebank. He's a charming shyster. He and Palmerston are kind of Boris-esque.
鲍里斯式的人物，对吧。是的。但在这里他不是“迪兹”，他不是迪斯雷利，他是比肯斯菲尔德。是的，比肯斯菲尔德伯爵。这是他取得的封号。是的，因为他热衷于浮华和排场。他看起来非常严肃。他看起来很有政治家的风范。迪兹，他不是迪斯雷利，他是比肯斯菲尔德。是的，比肯斯菲尔德伯爵。这是他取得的封号。是的，因为他热衷于浮华和排场。他看起来非常严肃。他看起来很有政治家的风范。
Boris figures, yeah. Yeah. But here he's not Dissey, he's not Disraeli, he's Beckensfield. Yeah, the Earl of Beckensfield. Is the title he took. Yeah, because he's all about the pageantry and the pomp. And he looks very serious. He looks statesmanlike. dizzy, he's not Disraeli, he's Beckensfield. Yeah, the Earl of Beckensfield. Is the title he took. Yeah, because he's all about the pageantry and the pomp. And he looks very serious. He looks statesmanlike.
是的，确实如此。为什么格莱斯顿不在这里？这是一个绝佳的问题，而我并不知道答案。也许是因为格莱斯顿那种……你知道的，他是伟大的平民领袖之类的人。但你会觉得，既然迪斯雷利在这里，格莱斯顿也应该在这里才对。是的。因为否则这就更说不通了。因为托利党人凭着德比伯爵占了不少风光……之类的事情。但你会觉得，如果迪斯雷利在这里，格莱斯顿也应该在这里。是的。因为否则，
Yeah, he does. Yeah. Why is Gladstone not here? That is an excellent question to which I don't know the answer. Maybe Gladstone because of his sort of, you know, he's a great commoner and all that sort of stuff. But you feel if Disraeli's here, then Gladstone should be here as well. Yeah. Because otherwise it makes more sense. Because the Tories have got a good run with the Earl of Derby as well sort of stuff. But you feel, if Disraeli's here, then Gladstone should be here as well. Yeah. Because otherwise,
这就说不通了。因为托利党人凭着德比伯爵也占了不少风光，当然。是的。赌徒的最爱。而且，这里没有工党政治家的身影。
it makes more sense. Because the Tories have got a good run with the Earl of Derby as well, of course. Yeah. The punter's favourite. And also, there isn't a Labour politician here.
没有。没有艾德礼。所以，我认为这也是一种缺失。所以我们应该竖立更多雕像，也就是……我认为我们应该立一座艾德礼的雕像。
No. No, Atlee, So again, I think that's a lack. So we should put up more statues, which is... I think we should have a statue of Atlee.
我认为我们应该立一座格莱斯顿的雕像。我认为我们应该立一座吉姆·卡拉汉的雕像。绝对应该。绝对应该。顺便说一句，我告诉你我们应该做什么：我们应该休息一下。是的，我们应该。
I think we should have a statue of Gladstone. I think we should have a statue of Jim Callaghan. Definitely. Definitely. And on that note, I'll tell you what we should have. We should have a break. Yeah, we should.
所以我们休息后重聚，然后我们将继续参观更多的雕像。再见。雕像，我们应有尽有。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻的固定节目，
So we shall reconvene after the break and we should be looking at more statues. Goodbye. Statues, we've got them. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news,
包含评论、少许娱乐圈八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们已经推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想听无广告音频、加更节目并提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。这就是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到我们中央伦敦之旅第三集充满雕塑的节日。我们在议会广场，现在正站在另一座雕像前……一个曾是
reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com hello welcome back to the statue fest that is the third episode of our tour of central london we're in parliament square and we are now standing in front of another statue um someone who was a
大英帝国子民的人，是的，但也是另一个国家的偶像——圣雄甘地。圣雄甘地，是的。当然，正如丘吉尔所称的那样，他是个“半裸的苦行僧”。所以我刚才说，我认为这是一种文化挪用。但甘地是对帝国的一种清算，不是吗？确实是的。他的雕像能立在那里。这座雕像是在2015年竖起来的。但这表面上就是它的意义所在。
subject of the british empire yes um but is an icon of another country mahatma gandhi mahatma gandhi yeah of course a half-naked fakir, as Churchill called him. So I was saying earlier that I think that this is an act of cultural appropriation. But Gandhi is a kind of reckoning with empire, isn't he? He is. The fact that his statue is there. So it went up in 2015. But that's ostensibly what it is.
是的。但我认为它暗中起到了提醒人们大英帝国“既想占有蛋糕又想吃掉它”的作用。嗯，这是一种……这是一种帝国式的……这是一种后帝国的道德。所以它客观上是在说我们反对帝国，但是嘿，看啊，我们在曾是帝国首都的中心，我们依然……我觉得这有点严苛了。我觉得他在这里就像是一位圣人，印度的圣人，而不是我们的圣人。是的，但你……我认为英国能为甘地树立一座雕像是一个很好的表态。对于那些不太了解的听众，用15秒简单概括一下甘地的一生？所以我想
Yeah. But I think it's kind of implicitly serving as a reminder of the british empire having a cake eating it well it's it's it's a it's it's a kind of imperial it's a kind of post-imperial morality so it's it's objectively saying we're against the empire but hey look you know we're in the center of what was the imperial capital and we're still i think that's a bit harsh i think it's i i think he's there as a saint actually he's india's saint he's not ours yeah but you i think it's a good statement that britain has a statue of gandhi for some for listeners who don't know what give us a quick pricey of gandhi's life in 15 seconds so i suppose
甘地——我的意思是，他是一个来到伦敦学习法律的印度人，是的。所以在某种意义上，他可以算作一个伦敦人，所以也许在这个层面上，他配得上在这里拥有一座雕像。他去了南非，然后回到印度，领导了推翻英属印度统治的独立斗争，见证了独立，随后被一名印度教民族主义者枪杀身亡。所以这是一个英雄般的人物。但就像史末资一样，他是英国故事的一部分。他是我们故事的一部分。
gandhi i mean he's he's um uh an indian who comes to study law actually in london yeah so in that sense he could count as a londoner so perhaps on that level, he deserves a statue here. He goes to South Africa, he goes back to India, he leads the fight for independence from the British Raj, gets to see independence and then gets shot by a Hindu nationalist and dies. So a kind of heroic figure. But as with Smuts, he's part of the British story. He is part of our story.
是的，他是。但我认为他的存在，我不知道，总让人觉得有点像是我们在将他据为己有，而我们其实并没有这个权利。我不这么认为。我觉得你的意思是这个广场应该充满
Yes, he is. But I think his existence here, I don't know, it just kind of slightly feels like we are kind of claiming him as our own when we don't really have the right to do that. I don't agree with that. I think you're basically saying the square should be full of
那些所谓进步人士会称之为“坏蛋”的人？我可没这么说，我完全没这么说。我的意思是，我觉得在某种意义上，将甘地据为己有，将曼德拉据为己有，并把他们放在议会广场的正中央，是在暗示“这些是英国式的人物”。我完全不觉得这是这个意思。我觉得这在说……我客观上知道那不是……我坚信那不是……他们是……我知道那不是初衷。但我认为这里隐含着一种
what kind of progressive people would call baddies i'm not saying that at all i'm not saying that at all what i'm saying is that i think that there is a sense in which appropriating gandhi appropriating mandela and putting them in in the middle of um parliament square is saying that you know these are kind of british figures i don't think it's saying that at all i think it's saying that i know objectively that's not that's not. I think it's saying that... I know, objectively, that's not... They're part of the... And I know that's not the rationale. But I think that there is a kind of implicit assumption
道德优越感的假设。所以我经常想，当你带一群孩子来这里，比如小学生或者什么人，这是许多孩子会驻足的雕像，即使他们不知道背后的故事，他们也会对这个身穿
of moral superiority here. So I often think these things, you know, you bring a load of kids here, primary school children or something, and this is a statue that a lot of them will stop at, even if they don't know the story, because they'll be intrigued by the figure, you know, who's in his kind of
长袍的人物感到好奇，这和周围的所有人都截然不同，这是一个绝佳的……我的意思是，如果别的都不算，这绝对是一个伟大的教育空间。你可以讲述这个故事。我想，关于它有趣的地方还在于——看看这两座雕像的左臂，它们几乎一模一样。是的，所以迪斯雷利穿着英国贵族的袍服，而甘地穿着那种粗糙的、手纺的……嗯，这难道不是一个动人的画面吗？我的意思是，现在就在身后……我的意思是，这一切很大程度上都关于帝国，不是吗？关于种族以及所有这些事情。
robes and stuff and it's so obviously so different from all the others and it's a great i mean it's actually if nothing else it's a great educative space i mean you can tell the story i suppose also what's interesting about it yeah and and look at and if you look at the left arm of both statues they're almost identical yeah so disraeli has the robes of a peer of the realm and Gandhi has the kind of the rough homespun of... Well, isn't that a lovely image? I mean, now just behind... I mean, so much of this is about empire, isn't it? And about race and all these kinds of things.
就在甘地肩膀的远处，是亚伯拉罕·林肯。我想亚伯拉罕·林肯几乎是同一个故事的一部分，因为这关乎黑人与白人之间的公正。这就是为什么……我的意思是，林肯之所以在那里，是因为我认为他是美国最伟大的总统。这也关乎说英语的人民，不是吗？我的意思是，同样，这也有点把林肯据为己有之意。我只是觉得……我完全不同意这种说法。我彻底驳斥这种观点。
And just over Gandhi's shoulder is in the distance is Abraham Lincoln. And Abraham Lincoln, I suppose, is almost part of the same story to the extent that it's about justice between sort of black and white. That's why I mean, Lincoln is there because he's I think it's he's America's greatest president. It's also about kind of English speaking peoples, isn't it? I mean, again, it's kind of claiming it Lincoln for our own. I just I think I just think that it's... I utterly disagree with that. I utterly refute this.
所以，林肯雕像，对吧？林肯雕像是美国赠送的礼物。就像华盛顿雕像一样。它是由劳埃德·乔治揭幕的。它在另一边。它隔着马路，所以我懒得走过去。但你从议会广场内就能看到它。
So the Lincoln, right? The Lincoln is a gift. The Lincoln is a gift from America. Like the Washington. And it was unveiled by Lloyd George. So it's on the other side. It's over the traffic so I can't be bothered to walk all the way over there. But you can see it from within Parliament Square.
它是在1920年第一次世界大战结束时，由这里的另一位人物劳埃德·乔治揭幕的。但当然，林肯的雕像现在在美国也有些被拆除了。因为林肯众所周知，尽管他是一名废奴主义者，并且在南北战争期间领导了北方，但他并不相信白人和黑人能够永远平等。他曾辩称，人与人之间将永远存在差异，白人种族应当永远占据优越地位。所以，以21世纪的标准来看，对某些人而言，林肯站在了历史的错误一边。对我来说，
It was unveiled by one of the other people in this square, Lloyd George, in 1920, at the end of the First World War. But of course, Lincoln statues, some of Lincoln's statues have been taken down in America now. Because Lincoln famously, although he was an abolitionist, and he led the North during the American Civil War, he didn't believe that white and black people could ever be equal. He argued that there would always be differences and the white race should always be superior um so by 21st century to some people by 21st century standards lincoln is on the wrong side of history um it seems an
把这样的话安在一个解放了黑奴、并在南北战争结束后签署《解放黑奴宣言》的人身上，是一件非同寻常的事。不过，话又说回来，汤姆，你会把林肯留下来的，对吧？我告诉你，我们把他据为己有了，他是一份礼物，一件礼物。是的，我想我对此并没有什么强烈的感觉。不过，接下来我们又得在成群的游客中杀出一条血路来看下一座雕像了。好吧，我们周围有很多警车驶过，对吧？是的。基本上，这都是这个人的错。罗伯特·皮尔。罗伯特·皮尔，警察制度的创始人。
extraordinary thing to me to say about the man who emancipated um slaves and the emancipation proclamation at the end of the american civil war but um but there you go you'd keep lincoln wouldn't you tom i tell you we've appropriated him he's a present he's a gift yeah i suppose i don't feel strongly about it either way but i'm now again we have to fight our way past hordes of tourists for this next one well we've had a lot of police cars going by haven't we yeah And basically that's this man's fault. Robert Peel. Robert Peel, founder of the police.
是的。塔姆沃思最深爱的儿子。塔姆沃思的骄傲。是的，塔姆沃思的骄傲。他把皮尔的雕像放在了塔姆沃思，旁边还有麦西亚女领主埃塞尔弗莱德，英格兰的奠基母亲，我……
Yeah. Tamworth's most beloved son. Pride of Tamworth. Yeah, the pride of Tamworth. He spent the statue of Peel in Tamworth along with Athelfland, Lady of the Mercians, the founding mother of England, who I...
你希望在这里看到她。我也希望在这里看到她，是的。你必须容忍罗伯特·皮尔吗？是的。我的意思是，你知道，罗伯特·皮尔是一位伟大的19世纪早期首相，极具历史影响力，他废除了《谷物法》。制作人正一脸怀疑地
You would like to see here. I'd like to see here, yeah. Did you have to tolerate Robert Peel? Yeah. I mean, you know, Robert Peel is a great early 19th century prime minister, very consequential, repeals the Corn Laws. The producer's looking sceptical
看着我，因为他觉得这与相关性论点有关，而且……不，他是一个重要人物，但我的意思是，他挺无聊的。托尼就是那个制作人……你知道的，他是我心中的普通人代表，我们把他带到播客中来作为国民的声音。他不太确定……那纳我 Nelson Mandela 呢？我其实觉得这是一个糟糕的……我的意思是，这是一个糟糕的说法，我其实觉得这是一座糟糕的雕像。为什么你觉得这是一座糟糕的雕像？因为它长得不像他。我觉得它看起来不太对劲，我觉得腿有点太短了。
because of his relevant arguments and, you know... No, he's an important figure, but I mean, he's quite boring. Tony's the producer who is the... You know, he's my important figure but i mean he's quite boring he's uh tony's tony the producer who is the you know he's my sort of common man that i um that we bring on the podcast to be the the voice of the nation he's not sure what about nelson mandela i actually think this is a terrible i mean this is an awful thing to say i actually think it's a bad statue why do you think it's a bad statue because it doesn't look like him i don't think it looks quite right i think the legs are a bit too short.
我很喜欢这件衬衫。纳尔逊·曼德拉的腿真的很短吗？你看，有个小女孩走过去抱住了他。抱住了他，那挺温馨的。但我不知道她抱他是因为知道他是纳尔逊·曼德拉，还是因为它是……现在有个男孩也跑过去加入了。我觉得这其中一定有一部分原因。真温馨的画面。
I quite like the shirt. Did Nelson Mandela have very short legs? Well, you see, family, small girl's gone up and hugged him. Hugged him, that's nice. But I'm not sure if she's hugging him because she knows he's Nelson Mandela or she's hugging him because it's... Now there's a boy going up to join. I think there must be a part of that. Great scenes.
他们可不会对罗伯特·皮尔这么做。话又说回来，他把这四个人都拿捏了。他有一个……不会对罗伯特·皮尔这么做。话又说回来，他确实为他们做了这些。他有一个巨大的基座。罗伯特·皮尔的基座大约有六英尺高。也对。那是个健康与安全隐患。我想，年轻时的桑德布鲁克肯定会冒着健康和安全的风险
They're not doing that to Robert Peel. Mind you, he deals with all four of them. He's on a doing that to Robert Peel. Mind you, he did it for them. He's got a massive plinth. Robert Peel's like a six-foot plinth. Fair enough. That's a health and safety hazard. I think surely the youthful Sandbrook would have risked health and safety
去拥抱罗伯特·皮尔爵士的腿。不，多米尼克，下来吧。去爬德比伯爵的雕像。妈妈，妈妈，我一定要抱。我一定要抱。我一定要抱罗伯特·皮尔爵士。不，多米尼克，下来。去爬德比伯爵的雕像。妈妈，妈妈，我一定要抱。我一定要抱。我一定要抱罗伯特·皮尔爵士。不管怎样，纳尔逊在这里。现在，我想，汤姆，这是你的……你准备要……
to hug the legs of Sir Robert Peel. No, Dominic, come down. And climb up the Isle of Derby. Mamma, mamma, I must hug. I must hug. I must hug Sir Robert Peel. No, Dominic, come down. And climb up the Earl of Derby. Mama, mama, I must hug. I must hug. I must hug Sir Robert Peel. Well, anyway, Nelson's here. Now, I suppose, Tom, this is your, you're going to, you know.
好吧，我已经说过了我要对它说的话。我已经表达过我的看法了。我的意思是，公平地说，你在62集播客之前就已经表达过你的看法了，但我不会因此而记恨你。确实，公平地说，你在62集播客之前就已经表达过你的看法了，但我不会因此而记恨你。我确实说过。我确实说过。我认为纳尔逊·曼德拉的雕像能立在这里是一件很棒的事，你知道，非国大（ANC）曾把伦敦当作他们的第二个家。是的，确实如此。你知道的，这至关重要。南岸有一尊纳尔逊·曼德拉的半身像。你知道，我觉得这很棒。我只是觉得议会广场，作为帝国首都的心脏，
Well, I've already said what I've got to say about that. I've already said what I've got to say. I mean, to be fair, you've said what you've got to say about 62 podcasts ago, but I don't hold that against you. I have, to be fair, you've said what you've got to say about 62 podcasts ago, but I don't hold that against you. I have. I have. I think it's great that the statues of Nelson Mandela, you know, ANC had London was kind of their second home. Yes, it was. You know, it's crucially important. There is a statue of the bust of Nelson Mandela on the South Bank. You know, I think that's great. I just think that Parliament Square, the hub of the imperial capital,
放在这里让我感觉有点可疑。这形成了一个完美的闭环。这里有像迪斯雷利这样绝对是帝国象征的人物——我的意思是，正是迪斯雷利授予了维多利亚女王“印度女皇”的称号。然后我认为，按时间顺序来看，你用甘地作为这个故事的句号。也许吧，也许吧。
it just feels slightly dodgy to me. It closes the circle. It has the people like, you know, Disraeli, who were absolutely emblematic of empire. I mean, it was Disraeli who gave Victoria the title Empress of India. And then I think you chronologically, you close the story with Gandhi. Maybe, maybe.
我觉得这给我的感觉有点不太对劲。它形成了一个闭环。这里面有像迪斯雷利这样的人，他们绝对是帝国的象征。我的意思是，正是迪斯雷利授予了维多利亚印度女皇的称号。然后我想，按时间顺序来看，故事的结尾是甘地。也许吧，也许吧。
Who fought for Indian independence. With Mandela who came to, you know, to embody reconciliation between black and white and a kind of post-colonial future. I think that is a nice story. Okay, I'm going to accept that you've thought more deeply about this than I have. This is, the producers are here with us now
谁为印度独立而战。曼德拉则体现了黑人与白人之间的和解以及某种后殖民时期的未来。我认为这是一个很好的故事。好吧，我承认你对这个问题的思考比我更深。制片人们现在和我们在一起
please excerpt this clip and put it as a special one-off broadcast no i'm just i yeah i okay i'm convinced tom has been very generous but i have to say tom has also been very gentleman and not mentioning it throughout this these three episodes i've been wearing a tom holland benefit year cap a tom holland themed baseball cap a tom holland themed baseball cap yeah it's been utterly humiliating because i forgot to bring it's very it's a beautiful sunny day unusually yeah i'm worried about getting sunburned and so i'm wearing a tom holland i mean it's even got your face on the front it's your face modeled as a lion's face it's backed against rajasthan where i bowled the prince of yudai purr um so that's what this is
请把这段剪辑摘录下来，作为一期特别的独立广播推出。不，我只是，我，好吧，我服了。汤姆非常慷慨，但我必须说，汤姆也非常有绅士风度，在过去的这三集里，他一直没有提这件事：我一直戴着一顶汤姆·霍兰德慈善年的帽子，一顶汤姆·霍兰德主题的棒球帽，一顶汤姆·霍兰德主题的棒球帽。是的，这简直太丢脸了，因为我忘了带……今天是个非常美好的晴天，反常的晴天。是的，我担心被晒伤，所以我戴着一顶汤姆·霍兰德……我的意思是，正面甚至还有你的脸。那是你的脸，被塑造成狮子的脸。它的背景是拉贾斯坦邦，我在那里保龄球击中了尤代普尔王子，嗯，所以这就是这个东西
all commemorating and it's wonderful that you've been broadcasting this to the uh to the people of central london i've seen a lot of people it's a shame actually shaking their head sadly when they see the cap it's a shame that this is um this is only audio because it would be a wonderful site for people and lots of people come up to me and say god you must love spider-man dominic i i can't believe that you pulled that low trick after the cap i mean come on okay so we've done parliament square there's two more statues that we do need to look at one of them is the statue of cromwell which we talked about in the episode with paul lay the other is the statue of richard i so we'll come to them but before we do that yeah standing next to parliament square we've got westminster abbey yeah and we've talked a lot actually um our very first podcast
所有的纪念活动，你能把它广播给伦敦市中心的人们，真是太棒了。我看到很多人——其实当他们看到这顶帽子时，无奈地摇着头，真是一种遗憾，这只是音频，因为这对人们来说会是一个奇妙的景象，很多人走过来对我说：“天哪，你一定很爱蜘蛛侠，多米尼克。”我不敢相信你在帽子事件后使出那种低劣的把戏，我的意思是，拜托！好吧，我们已经看过了议会广场，还有两座雕像我们需要看一看。其中一座是我们在与保罗·莱（Paul Lay）的节目中讨论过的克伦威尔雕像，另一座是理查德一世雕像，所以我们会讲到它们。但在那之前，是的，站在议会广场旁边的就是威斯敏斯特教堂，是的，其实我们讨论了很多，嗯，在我们的第一期播客中
we were talking about ideas of greatness and then of saintliness we were and we've talked about martyrs and there are literal martyrs um above the great west door of westminster abbey so i think we should go and have a look at them because I think that they're a fascinating counterpoint to the array of kind of secular power that we get in Parliament Square. Any excuse to do church mongering. Yeah, so let's cross the road and we'll join there. So, Tom, you've dragged me to the front of Westminster Abbey.
我们讨论了伟大和圣洁的概念。确实如此。我们还讨论了殉道者，威斯敏斯特教堂伟大西门上方就有真实的殉道者。所以我想我们应该去看看他们，因为我认为他们与我们在议会广场看到的世俗权力阵容形成了迷人的对照。任何去教堂转转的借口。好的，让我们过马路，在那儿汇合。那么，汤姆，你把我拉到了威斯敏斯特教堂门前。
Very nice, of course, lovely abbey but i want to know why i'm here what have you got for me okay so we're looking at the the west doorway um and above the west doorway there were vacant niches for um presumably biblical figures or biblical kings or saints or whatever would have gone up and they were empty so um beginning of the 21st century they they put up statues of people who'd been martyred for Christian faith over the course of the 20th century. And they are of international scope. So we were just talking in Parliament Square about the international character of commemoration. Here, it's absolutely Catholic in the small C sense, kind of universal church.
当然很好，很可爱的修道院，但我想知道我为什么在这里，你给我准备了什么？好的，所以我们正在看西门，在西门上方有空置的壁龛，大概是留给圣经人物、圣经国王、圣洁的人或诸如此类的人的，它们原来是空的。所以，在21世纪初，他们竖起了20世纪为基督教信仰殉道的人的雕像。而且他们的影响范围是国际性的。所以我们刚才在议会广场讨论了纪念活动的国际特征。在这里，它完全具有小写c意义上的天主教特征，也就是某种普世教会。
So in the middle, you have Martin Luther King is one of them. You've got Oscar Romero, who was the Archbishop of El Salvador, who was shot celebrating mass. You've got a guy with the beard on the left is Maximilian Kolbe, who was a Polish priest who sacrificed himself, I think, in Auschwitz. He died in concentration camp. And you've got one of the Grand Duchesses in Russia who was thrown down a coal mine by the communists. You've got people from China. So you've got people
所以在中间，马丁·路德·金就是其中之一。你还有奥斯卡·罗梅罗，他是萨尔瓦多大主教，在主持弥撒时被枪杀。左边那个留胡子的人是马克西米利安·科尔贝，他是一位波兰神父，我想他在奥斯威辛牺牲了，死在集中营里。俄罗斯的一位女大公也被布尔什维克扔进了煤矿。你还有来自中国的人。所以你有来自
from across the world. But the thing is that they, you know, we've been talking about how most of the statues that we've been looking at are people who have killed. These are people who are here because they were killed.
世界各地的人。但问题是，你知道的，我们一直在讨论我们看过的绝大多数雕像都是被杀的人。这些人之所以在这里，是因为他们被杀了。
Dietrich Bonhoeffer. Yeah, so Bonhoeffer, yes. So I suppose they're a bit like Edith Cavellll who was in our first episode she was um but so these are martyrs but Tom I mean this you were arguing before about appropriation you don't think this is kind of Britain I mean you have all these international figures don't you if you sort of think you're the center of the world and you want to no because because this is a church and it was built as a Catholic church and it has always celebrated saints from across the world.
迪特里希·朋霍费尔。是的，所以朋霍费尔，是的。所以我想他们有点像伊迪丝·卡维尔，她曾在我们的第一期节目中出现过，她是……但所以这些是殉道者，但是汤姆，我的意思是，你之前在争论挪用（appropriation）的问题，你不认为这有点像英国吗？我的意思是，你有所有这些国际人物，难道不是因为你觉得自己是世界的中心，你想……不，因为这是一座教堂，它建时就是一座天主教教堂，而且它一直都在赞颂来自世界各地的圣徒。
It claims a universal jurisdiction, which, of course, the British state does not. And do you distinguish between these statues, which are on the facade of the church, as so many statues have been through history, but they're of real people, Martin Luther King. Do you think there's a difference between them and the Parliament Square secular statues? Yes, completely. Even though Martin Luther King, he's the same kind of figure as Nelson Mandela and Gandhi, isn't he? Why is he different just because he's on the facade of a church?
它宣称拥有普世管辖权，而英国政府显然没有。你是否区分了这些位于教堂正面的雕像（历史上许多雕像都是如此，但它们是真人，比如马丁·路德·金）与议会广场的世俗雕像？是的，完全不同。尽管马丁·路德·金和纳尔逊·曼德拉以及甘地是同一种人物，不是吗？为什么仅仅因为他在教堂正面，他就与众不同？
Well, Martin Luther King is being celebrated as a Christian here. Okay. Who is being, you know, implication is that he was shot as a martyr for for his faith which i suppose in a sense he was i mean i agree that's controversial but it's from the ideological point of view yeah it's an interesting counterpoint to the traditions of heroism that we were talking about in the first episode that we ever did from the rest of the greatness yeah we talked about greatness well even in that episode we sort of trod a line between greatness and sainthood didn't we
嗯，马丁·路德·金在这里是被当作一个基督徒来颂扬的。好吧。他的暗示是，他作为信仰的殉道者而被枪杀——我想在某种程度上他确实是。我的意思是，我同意这很有争议，但从意识形态的角度来看，是的，它与我们在有史以来的第一期节目中讨论过的英雄主义传统形成了一个有趣的对比，从其余的伟大……是的，我们讨论了伟大。嗯，甚至在那一期节目中，我们也在伟大和圣洁之间划清了界限，不是吗？
people are more interested you know that the idea of heroism really has become one with which we're embarrassed yeah whereas the idea of of uh of martyrdom i think is one that that we're more comfortable with yeah i think there's a lot of truth in that so uh because we're more i think to embrace the victim now maybe than the so yeah and the conqueror if you like so i think i think there's a lot of truth in that so uh because we're more keen to embrace the victim now maybe than the so yeah and the conqueror if you like so i think i think that that's um you know it's it's an interesting counterpoint that yeah you know those statues are obviously not nearly as well known as the statues in parliament square uh and often people can go in westminster abbey and not look up and see them at all. Yeah. But, you know, Westminster Abbey is the, you know,
人们更感兴趣的是，你知道的，英雄主义的概念确实已经变得让我们感到尴尬，而殉道主义的概念，我认为是我们更能接受的。是的，我认为这其中有很多真相。所以，因为我们现在可能更热衷于拥抱受害者，而不是……是的，还有征服者，如果你愿意的话。所以我想，这其中有很多真相。所以，因为我们现在可能更热衷于拥抱受害者，而不是……是的，还有征服者，如果你愿意的话。所以我想，这是一个有趣的对照，那些雕像显然不如议会广场的雕像那么知名，人们走进威斯敏斯特教堂时，经常不会抬头看它们一眼。是的。但是，你知道，威斯敏斯特教堂是……
it's the religious equivalent of Westminster. It's the religious heart of the country. But, Tom, in the very first episode that we did about statues, which probably for our listeners seems about a lifetime ago. Yeah. You were talking about the Greeks and the Romans, particularly the Romans and their influence on statuary. And I'm surprised you didn't talk about medieval saints and people of that kind because
它是威斯敏斯特的宗教对应物。它是这个国家的宗教中心。但是，汤姆，在我们关于雕像的第一期播客中——对我们的听众来说，那可能好像是一生前的事了——是的，你当时在谈论希腊人和罗马人，尤其是罗马人及其对雕塑的影响。我很惊讶你没有谈论中世纪的圣徒和类似的人物，因为
surely they're they're also obvious precursors because i think that's the tradition that the 17th century resurrection of um of roman sculpture kind of supersedes okay um because celebrating saints with statues is obviously a catholic thing which then gets erased with the reformation so in a sense perhaps you could say that um starting to to put up statues of kings dressed in in roman costume yeah is a way of replacing that hunger for sculptures of of human individuals that Protestantism had effectively destroyed when they closed down the monasteries. See, I think there's a huge issue, which we talked about in our Culture Wars podcast,
它们当然也是显而易见的先驱，因为我认为那是17世纪罗马雕塑复兴所取代的传统。好吧，因为用雕像来赞颂圣徒显然是一件天主教的事情，后来随着宗教改革而被抹去了。所以在某种程度上，也许可以说，开始竖立穿着罗马长袍的国王雕像，是一种取代新教在关闭修道院时实际上已经摧毁的对人类个人雕塑渴望的方式。看，我认为有一个巨大的问题，我们在文化战争播客中讨论过，
of people's anxiety about images. Yeah. Which is, we've talked about Garyary young's article in the in the guardian yeah which said that all statues should be pulled down i think that that is that is a kind of enduring anxiety and i think that um a lot of the anxiety around all the political figures here so people have targeted churchill who you know basically saved britain and the world from fascism and but they also targeted Gandhi. Yes, they did.
人们对图像的焦虑。是的，我们讨论了加里·扬在《卫报》上的文章，是的，文章说所有的雕像都应该被推倒。我认为这是一种挥之不去的焦虑，并且我认为，围绕这里所有政治人物的许多焦虑——人们针对丘丘吉尔（他基本上拯救了英国和世界免受法西斯主义的侵害），但他们也针对甘地。是的，他们确实这么做了。
The man who won independence for India, but was accused of racism. See, I think there's a human impulse to tear down heroes, to create heroes, but also there's an enduring desire to tear them down. And that's why attacking Churchill and Gandhi, probably of all the, apart from Mandela, of all the people we've talked about, the most loved, the most associated with virtue of various kinds. I think that's why they were targeted. Well, I think also they were
那个为印度赢得独立却被指控为种族主义者的人。看，我认为人类有一种推倒英雄、创造英雄的冲动，但同时也有一种挥之不去的将他们推倒的渴望。这就是为什么攻击丘丘吉尔和甘地——除了曼德拉之外，在我们讨论过的所有人中，他们可能是最受爱戴、与各种美德联系最紧密的人。我想这就是他们成为目标的原因。嗯，我认为他们也是
targeted because they were racists. I think that's an important part of it. I mean, if you're going to be as reductive as that, surely that is true of all the people on par. I mean, was the Earl of Derby, were they Israeli? Did they not have prejudices that would seem alien to us now? I think it's a tension between the idea of a hero and the idea of a saint. And with a saint, you accept that they're fallen. They're human. So the fact that they're sinners is kind of factored in theologically. With heroes, it becomes more complicated because we don't have the… Right, yeah. I'm talking of saints and sinners.
因为他们是种族主义者而成为目标的。我认为这是其中的重要一部分。我的意思是，如果你要得出如此简单化的结论，这肯定适用于议会广场上的所有人？我的意思是，德比伯爵（Earl of Derby）难道没有偏见吗？他们难道没有在我们看来显得格格不入的偏见吗？我认为这是英雄的概念和圣洁的概念之间的紧张关系。对于圣徒，你承认他们是堕落的，他们是凡人。因此，他们在神学上已经被视为罪人。对于英雄来说，事情变得更加复杂，因为我们没有……对，是的。说到圣徒、罪人和
And heroes. One of my absolute all-time… We have now arrived outside the Palace of Westminster. The star of my favourite figures in all history. The Lord Protector, Oliver Cromwell. I love this statue. So, Dominic, you're winning us all kinds of listeners in Ireland. Of course, of course.
英雄。我所有经历中最绝对的……我们现在来到了威斯敏斯特宫外。我历史最爱人物中的明星，护国公奥利弗·克伦威尔。我喜欢这座雕像。所以，多米尼克，你在爱尔兰为我们赢得了各种各样的听众。当然，当然。
So every time I walk past this with my son, who's half Irish, I always say, oh, let's pay homage to the great man. And my wife kind of sighs and rolls her eyes. So this was very controversial, Tom, even at the time. It's brought up in 1899 by Hanno Thornycroft. A Liberal MP at the time, John George Fillimore, Tom, even at the time. It's put up in 1899 by Hanno Thornycroft. A liberal MP at the time, John George Fillimore, said, any man who could object to a statue of Cromwell must be imbued with bigotry and party spirit in the highest degree.
所以每次我和我那有一半爱尔兰血统的儿子散步路过这里时，我总是说：“哦，让我们向伟人致敬吧。”我妻子则会叹气并翻白眼。所以这在当时是非常有争议的，汤姆。它是由哈诺·索尼克罗夫特（Hanno Thornycroft）于1899年竖立的。当时的自由党议员约翰·乔治·菲利莫尔（John George Fillimore）——汤姆，甚至在当时，它是在1899年由哈诺·索尼克罗夫特竖立的。当时的自由党议员约翰·乔治·菲利莫尔说，任何反对克伦威尔雕像的人都必然带有极度的偏执和党派精神。
Goodness. Well, that's Ireland told. Yeah, exactly. So, of course, the Irish nationalists. Who were the Irish nationalists who were sitting in this building at the time, because they were part of the House of commons they all voted against and the tories voted against because you know the man who killed a king but the liberals got it through we we so in in the first episode we opened at the statue of charles the first yeah and i said then
天哪。好吧，这下爱尔兰被数落了。是的，确实如此。所以，当然，爱尔兰民族主义者。那些当时坐在这个建筑里的爱尔兰民族主义者，因为他们是下议院的一部分，他们都投了反对票，而托利党也投了反对票，因为你知道的，那个杀死国王的人。但自由党通过了它。我们在第一期节目中是以查理一世的雕像开场的，是的，我当时说
that i liked the fact that he's looking down we commemorate the civil war by having statue of charles first at one end of white hall and a statue of cromwell at the other um i would feel uncomfortable having a statue of cromwell if it wasn't balanced by a statue of charles the first and i don't i don't think the irish listeners will say oh now that i hear there's a statue of charles thei i feel a lot better well the war in ireland was a war over you know it was a civil war in which the two proponents were you know cromwell was there to fight royalists yeah um so actually having having those two figures is a way of paying honor to people who fought in very committed ways on both sides i think that's a
我喜欢他向下看的姿态。我们通过在白厅的一端设立查理一世的雕像，在另一端设立克伦威尔的雕像来纪念内战。嗯，如果没有查理一世的雕像来平衡，我站在克伦威尔的雕像旁会感到不舒服。我不认为爱尔兰听众会说：“哦，既然我听说这里有查理一世的雕像，我感觉好多了。”嗯，爱尔兰的战争是一场关于……你知道的，这是一场内战，其中两个支持者——克伦威尔去那里是为了与保皇党作战，是的。所以实际上，拥有这两个雕像是一种向那些在双方都以极其坚定的方式战斗过的人致敬的方式。我认为这是一个
very elaborate way of putting what's basically an accident. It is an accident. Absolutely it is an accident. It wasn't deliberate. But it is a way of solving the kind of inevitable tensions and conflicts that you have. Just like, you know, we took Parliament Square, I think that Churchill should be balanced by Attlee and I think that Disraeli
非常详尽的说法，用来表达基本上是一场意外的事情。这确实是一场意外。绝对是一场意外。这不是刻意的。但这是一种解决你必然会遇到的紧张关系和冲突的方式。就像，你知道的，我们占领了议会广场，我认为丘吉尔应该由艾德礼来平衡，我认为迪斯雷利
should be balanced by Gladstone. He's all about balance. I think it is important. In a public space like this, you need balance. There are all kinds of ironies, aren't there, with the Cromwell statue. I mean, Cromwell's here as a champion of parliamentary democracy, but he, of course, is the man who kicked out Parliament. Yeah, closed it down. Also, I mean, the other thing that this bears witness to is the fact that Cromwell, in a
应该由格莱斯顿来平衡。这一切都是为了平衡。我认为这很重要。在这样一个公共空间里，你需要平衡。克伦威尔的雕像有着各种各样的讽刺意味，不是吗？我的意思是，克伦威尔在这里作为议会民主的捍卫者，但他当然是那个把议会赶出去的人。是的，把它关闭了。此外，我的意思是，这所证明的另一件事是，克伦威尔在某种
sense, and we talked about this with Paul Leigh, is a 19th century creation. So the Cromwell who is idolized and the Cromwell who is hated, people who enshrine him as the great founder of parliamentary liberty and the people who condemn him as a kind of genocidal precursor of Hitler. Both of them are indulging in creative anachronism yes and i suppose in a sense an awful lot of what we've been talking about is creative and of course it is and that's true of a lot of the statues and talking of creative anachronism yeah we've got one last one last statue magnificent display you wouldn't forgive me if i didn't point out that he's behind that cromwell is behind bars which i think tony you see as some sort of metaphor do you but but obviously the reason for that is that Parliament is a terrorist threat.
意义上——我们和保罗·莱讨论过——是一个19世纪的创造物。所以，那个被偶像化的克伦威尔和那个被痛恨的克伦威尔，那些把他奉为议会自由伟大奠基人的人，以及那些谴责他是希特勒式种族灭绝先驱的人，两者都在沉溺于创造性的时代错误中。是的，我想在某种程度上，我们一直在谈论的很大一部分内容都是创造性的……当然是的，许多雕像都是如此。说到创造性的时代错误，是的，我们有最后一个，最后一座雕像，宏伟的展示。如果你不指出他身后是克伦威尔，而克伦威尔被关在铁栏杆后面，你会原谅我的，我想你托尼认为这是一种隐喻，不是吗？但显然这样做的原因是议会是一个恐怖主义威胁。
And the two groups of people who have committed terrorist attacks in Westminster over the past few decades, first Irish Republicans, for whom the statue of Cromwell is a standing provocation. Yes, that's true. The other are Islamist terrorists, for whom our final statue, likewise, it might be thought, is a standing provocation. Because our final statue is an equestrian image of Richard Coeur de Lion, Richard I, the 12th century king who led the Third Crusade to recapture Jerusalem. And there's a nice parallel here, Tom, a nice bit of symmetry. We started this trilogy seven years ago with the statue of Charles I, another equestrian statue, another king of England,
而在过去几十年里在威斯敏斯特发动恐怖袭击的两群人，首先是爱尔兰共和军，对他们来说，克伦威尔的雕像是一个持续的挑衅。是的，这是真的。另一群是伊斯兰恐怖分子，对他们来说，我们的最后一座雕像同样可以被认为是一个持续的挑衅。因为我们的最后一座雕像是理查德·狮心王（Richard Coeur de Lion）、理查德一世的骑马雕像，这位12世纪的国王曾领导第三次十字军东征去收复耶路撒冷。这里有一个很好的平行，汤姆，一个很好的对称。我们在七年前以查理一世的雕像开始了三部曲，那是另一座骑马雕像，另一位英格兰国王，
Charles I, king of England, Scotland. And here we are with another mounted king on a horse, a rather more impressive figure, I have to say, than Charles I, who's basically a bit of a fop um richard the first but a controversial figure i suppose i mean he basically spent most of his reign out of england fighting saracens didn't he yeah and so kind of in this you know a standing provocation i thought to anyone who wants to see the establishment of a caliphate um it's kind of you know bring it on
英格兰、苏格兰国王查理一世。现在我们有了另一位骑在马上的国王，一个比查理一世更令人印象深刻的人物——我必须这么说，查理一世基本上有点像个花花公子。嗯，理查德一世却是一个有争议的人物，我想——我的意思是，他基本上把大部分统治时期都花在了英格兰之外与萨拉森人作战，不是吗？是的，所以在某种程度上，你知道的，这对任何想要看到哈里发国建立的人来说都是一个持续的挑衅，这有点像，你知道的，放马过来吧。
but but the other the other thing about him is that um rather like uh buddhica he was no friend of london because he famously said that that he would cheerfully have sold london if it would raise him enough money oh my god to pay for his crusade like me uh yes it has my my take on london um so uh but he was never here i mean he was endlessly off in the holy land or fighting in france so this is another statue with interesting history an amusing history so um it was designed originally for the great exhibition by a man called baron maro ketty and you know what the newspapers called him something offensive count maro fatty did? Was that in the Daily Mail?
但是，但是关于他的另一件事是，嗯，有点像布狄卡，他可不是伦敦的朋友，因为他曾出名地说过，只要能筹集到足够的资金——天哪——来支付他的十字军东征费用，他会很高兴地把伦敦卖掉。像我一样，是的，这就是我对伦敦的看法。所以，嗯，但他从来不在这里，我的意思是，他没完没了地待在圣地或在法国打仗。所以这是另一座有着有趣历史、滑稽历史的雕像。所以，它最初是由一个叫巴伦·马罗凯蒂（Baron Marochetti）的人为伟大的博览会设计的，你知道报纸是怎么称呼他的吗？叫一些带有侮辱性的名字，伯爵马罗法蒂（Count Marofatty）？那是《每日邮报》登的吗？
Probably. Well, Daily Mail didn't exist then, but I'm sure they would have called him that. So he did this. And a lot of people said it was awful because actually, if you look closely, the chain mail that he's wearing
可能吧。嗯，《每日邮报》当时还不存在，但我确信他们会那样叫他。所以他做了这个。很多人说这很糟糕，因为实际上，如果你仔细看，他穿着的链甲
is skin tight. So it clings to his muscles in a way that's utterly implausible. I quite like that. The poetry anthologist, Francis Turner Paulgrave, this is my final quote of this trilogy, said, it was an essentially vulgar and low-class work, precisely on the grounds, Tom, that call forth the wonder of uncultivated spectators.
是紧身皮肤的。所以它以一种完全不符合逻辑的方式贴在他的肌肉上。我挺喜欢这个的。诗歌选集编者弗朗西斯·特纳·帕尔夫雷夫（Francis Turner Palgrave）——这是我这三部曲的最后一句引言——说，这是一部本质上粗俗且低级的工作，恰恰是因为这个原因，汤姆，它唤起了未经开化的观众的惊叹。
Well, I'm an uncultivated spectator because I quite like it. I quite like it. Didn't it get hit by a bomb in the Second World War and they had to repair the sword? A bomb exploded nearby. I think just missed it. And the sword got broken and they had to replace it. Exactly. I think that's the story. Yes. So it's a weird one that is here, isn't it?
好吧，我就是一个未经开化的观众，因为我挺喜欢它的。我挺喜欢它。它在二战中不是被炸弹击中过吗，他们不得不修缮宝剑？一枚炸弹在附近爆炸了。我想差一点就击中了。剑断了，他们不得不换掉它。没错。我想就是这个故事。是的。所以这是一个奇怪的东西，它在这里，不是吗？
Because he was a king who was absent for most of the time. Yeah, so all the kings. The statues of the kings. We've got Rich I, who wanted to sell London and was never here. We've got Charles I, who was so useless they chopped his head off. We've got James II, who got driven into exile. And George IV, who was just a basic fat sausage. They're all
因为他是一位大部分时间都不在场的国王。是的，所以所有的国王。国王们的雕像。我们有理查一世，他想卖掉伦敦却从来不在这里；我们有查理一世，他太无用了以至于被砍了头；我们有詹姆斯二世，他被赶入了流亡；还有乔治四世，他基本上就是个胖香肠。他们全都是
hopeless. But in a way, I kind of like that. Oh, and then opposite, we've got George V. Stamp collecting. Led the world in stamp collecting. But also led Britain through the First World War. Jolly good king, generally, I would say say I called the current Queen Lilibet
无药可救的。但某种程度上，我挺喜欢这样的。哦，然后对面，我们有乔治五世。集邮。引领了世界集邮潮流。但也带领英国度过了第一次世界大战。总的来说是个好国王，我想我会说，我管现任女王叫莉莉贝特（Lilibet），
thereby inspiring the name of Harry and Meghan's new daughter oh it's so nice that they brought it back to Meghan it's what she would want
从而启发了哈里和梅根新女儿的名字。哦，他们把它带回给梅根真是太好了，这正是她想要的。
isn't it so there's a link yeah so it all connects it all joins up so we began with Charles I and we've ended
难道不是吗？所以这其中有联系，是的，所以这一切都串联起来了，这一切都融汇贯通了。所以我们以查理一世开始，我们以
with Princess Meghan Princess Meghan Princess Meghan one day one day she'll have a statue here yeah you think
梅根公主、梅根公主、梅根公主结束。有一天，总有一天她会在这里拥有一座雕像。是的，你觉得吗？
I think we don't know how we've solved the whole statue dilemma well I think One day she'll have a statue here. Yeah. You think? I think we've solved the whole statue dilemma. Well, I think, have we not decided they should all stay and we should just build more? No, I think we've decided we should keep them all. We should get rid of the lot. Really? Yeah. I don't recall us coming to that conclusion.
我想我们不知道我们是如何解决整个雕像困境的。好吧，我想有一天她会在这里拥有一座雕像。是的。你觉得？我想我们已经解决了整个雕像困境。好吧，我想，难道我们没有决定它们都应该留下来，而我们只应该建造更多的雕像吗？不，我想我们已经决定应该把它们全部保留。我们应该把它们全扔掉。真的吗？是的。我不记得我们得出过这个结论。
Well, I think I said that about the statues in Parliament Square. I was quite afraid of getting rid of the lot. That was a mad thesis. Anyway, we've had a very jolly walk. It's been very sunny. We've done three episodes. Also, you've changed my mind. Yes.
好吧，我想我是对议会广场上的雕像这么说的。我挺害怕把它们全扔掉的。那是个疯狂的论点。无论如何，我们进行了一次非常愉快的散步。天气很好。我们录了三集。而且，你改变了我的主意。是的。
Now, that does not happen often. I don't think that's ever happened. Even as we speak, the producers are thinking about ways to animate that, put it on Twitter as a clip. I'm still wearing my Tom Holland baseball cap, which is a cheap one. So, in a way, I've been humiliated, but you've been even more humiliated. That's what I like to do. This podcast is all about.
这可不常见。我觉得这从来没发生过。就在我们说话的时候，制片人们正在考虑如何把这个做成动画，作为剪辑发到推特上。我仍然戴着我的汤姆·霍兰德棒球帽，这是一顶便宜的帽子。所以，某种程度上，我被羞辱了，但你被羞辱得更惨。这就是我喜欢做的。这个播客的全部意义所在。
So we've evened out. On that note, to our remaining listener, we say thank you for staying with us. And we will see you next time when we will be back in the studio, at least our own homes, and talking about something else. That's not about statues. Yeah. Bye-bye. All right. Goodbye.
所以我们扯平了。带着这种心情，对我们剩下的听众，我们要说感谢你们一直陪伴着我们。我们下次再见，届时我们将回到录音室，至少是我们自己的家里，谈论别的事情。那不是关于雕像的事情。好的。再见。好吧。再见。
Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com that's There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家分集、提前解锁、无广告收听并加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。目前本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。